thanks to skillshare for supporting this
episode of journey to the micro cosmos
the first 1000 people to click the link
in the description
can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
let us start today's episode by getting
to know our master of microscopes
james a little more up close and
personal
your screen is currently awash in
james's
blood fortunately this was a planned
affair
james didn't accidentally cut himself in
a slide and bleed all over it he simply
placed a drop on the slide
and let the cells do the rest and so
in observing his blood under the
microscope james is joining a long
tradition of scientists who have
examined blood belonging to themselves
to other animals and to other organisms
so that we can decipher the role this
fluid plays
in keeping us alive
[Music]
it's been hard for us as humans to miss
the fact that blood is
important to our bodies but
understanding the nature
and mechanisms of it has required
untangling the macroscopic structures
that send blood coursing through our
veins and the microscopic
details that make blood what it is
one of our early methods of describing
and categorizing the body
were the four humors a system developed
by ancient greek physicians who believed
our body could be described as the
interplay between
yellow bile black bile phlegm
and blood but blood is more than just
the substance itself
the fluid is nothing without a way to
use it
and so our understanding of blood is
tied up in our understanding of
the whole system the circulatory system
to get to what that means let's start by
looking at the blood of something a bit
different from us daphnia
[Music]
one thing that makes daphnia handy for
our purposes
is that you can you know literally see
right through them and with a microscope
you can observe the rapid
beating of its heart and the flow of
blood cells through its body
daphnia are also an invertebrate and
like many other invertebrates
it passes cells and ions and other
important molecules throughout its body
using a watery fluid called hemolymph
their hemolymph isn't constrained to
veins or arteries
instead it's pumped into an open cavity
called the hemoseal
where it then comes in contact with the
organs it needs to deliver nutrients to
this is an open circulatory system
vertebrates like us on the other hand
use a closed circulatory system where
blood is directed throughout our body in
a contained network of blood vessels
that system allows for more efficiency
in delivering oxygen throughout our body
but it's also
more complex and requires more energy
compared to the open circulatory system
now it took us quite a while to piece
together what our
circulatory system would look like the
2nd century physician galen
theorized that blood is made in our
livers using the remnants of digested
food
and when blood arrived at whatever spot
it was needed it was
then consumed galen's hypothesized path
mistook the nature of blood and the
structure of the heart
and yet it was a theory that would
prevail in medicine
for centuries in the 13th century the
arab physician ibn al-nafiz
drew on his study of animals to
correctly describe how a circulatory
system works
and yet his revolutionary work was not
widely known
until 1924 when an egyptian physician
found a copy of it
in the berlin state library while
working on his dissertation
in the 17th century english physician
william harvey came to draw the same
picture of the circulatory system
turning to demonstrations on dissected
animals to gruesomely illustrate his
point
and his work would in turn go on to
change our understanding of blood
emphasizing that it is a thing made and
circulated by our bodies and not
as galen predicted a product of our
digestion
so what are some of the pieces that make
up our blood
it's complex and variable of course but
let's
first focus on the color for many
invertebrates
the hemolymph is either clear or tinted
yellow with
pigment molecules and you might be
thinking right now i've squashed a fly
before and
there was a lot of red and yes perhaps
there was red but that was actually due
to the pigments
in the insects eyes not their blood
but biology does love an exception which
takes us back to the daphnia
as well as to another invertebrate
called artemia
both of these invertebrates blood
contains a protein that is familiar to
us
hemoglobin hemoglobin is the four
part protein inside our red blood cells
that makes
them red and more importantly hemoglobin
attaches to oxygen when a red blood cell
gets to our lungs the hemoglobin binds
to oxygen
turning the red blood cell into our own
personal oxygen transport machine now
there are other oxygen binding molecules
used by other animals but daphnia and
artemia both
turn to hemoglobin when times get tough
when the waters around them get low in
oxygen
they adapt by producing more and more
hemoglobin so they can capture
more of that precious resource
as they produce more hemoglobin the
populations of daphnia and artemia
become
visibly redder like they're blushing
which might
explain why they don't just have
hemoglobin lying around in large
quantities all the time
not only does it take energy to make
hemoglobin it makes the animals
more visible to predators when you look
at james's blood cells you can see the
red
of the hemoglobin but as we said at the
start of this episode
james is one of a long line of
scientists who have examined their blood
under the microscope some of the early
microscopic studies of human blood
relied on samples taken from
clots or from a recently fed laos
james has actually made a note on the
script here it says glad i didn't have
to do this
but of course one of the early adopters
of the self-study approach
was none other than the early master of
microscope's anthony
van lievenhock who described the quote
sanguinous globules of his own blood in
a letter to the royal society of london
centuries later dr carl landsteiner
would collect samples from six of his
co-workers and himself
to study how these different blood
samples and the antibodies within them
reacted to each other these observations
would lead him to describe
the human [ __ ] blood grouping system
we have always known that our blood was
vital in both senses of that word
and though we have now teased apart much
of its true nature its
significance reaches beyond the
scientific understanding
we talk of blood relations and being
hot-blooded or red-blooded blood
is always available to us both for
science
and symbolism for medicine and metaphor
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us
we'd also like to say thanks again to
skillshare for supporting this video
you can learn many many things on
skillshare even
how to make your own blood well
digital blood at least with classes like
animating blood flow
in a vessel with cinema 4d you'll learn
unsurprisingly
how to animate blood flow in a vessel in
cinema 4d
but you'll also learn skills like
modeling texturing
lighting animating rendering and
compositing
that will help you across any other 3d
animation project you hope to tackle
in the future skillshare is an online
learning community that offers
membership
with meaning with so much to explore
real world projects to create and the
support of fellow creatives
skillshare empowers you to accomplish
real growth
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning there are no
ads to distract you and they are always
launching new premium classes
so you can stay focused and follow
wherever your creativity takes you
and an annual subscription to skillshare
is less than ten dollars a month
if you're one of the first 1000 people
to click the link in the description
you can get a free trial of skillshare's
premium membership
now on to the people on the screen right
now these are our patreon patrons
without them our show literally could
not exist and we are
so thankful to them if you like what we
do and you want to help us keep making
it you can join those people
at patreon.com journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss
check out jam and germs on instagram and
if you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
you